[Music]
welcome back we just heard from
kate houston a few minutes ago she was
just north of where this plane crash
happened in the southwest valley
and i am just west of where it happened
we're at hinson and raven i'll give you
a live look here at the crash site you
can see a part of that plane
is sticking up by that fence that we
were known that where this crash
happened is right by that wall you can
see it
is scorched and that trailer on the
other side is scorched as well we did
talk to a man
who was out here working in a nearby lot
he saw this plane going very low
he saw the wing actually uh make some
odd movements he said that propeller was
not working
and he says he actually saw the man
inside of that plane open the door and
actually look outside
thinking that man was going to jump and
by the time he walked out here that
plane had crashed now
take a look at this video this is shot
by him this is of that sight there you
can see the flames
from this plane crash he said he tried
to help the man but there was nothing
that he could actually really do he
walked over there and so did a lot of
other neighbors here in this area a lot
of people
wondering what exactly happened but he
said that he actually thought that that
pilot
was going to be landing on raven because
he was so low he thought maybe
he was going to jump out of that plane
here onto raven but as soon as he had
took a turn
he that plane actually tilted and then
crashed right by that fence here
right near hinson and raven but this
investigation obviously continuing
corners just arrived here on scene
we'll continue to update you with the
very latest reporting live in the
southwest valley i'm joe mohler eight
news now we'll be right back